وهذه العائله مشهود لها بوطنيتها مشهود
لها بصمودها مشهود لها بشلال الشهداء الذي
قدمته لاجل الوطن ومشهود لها انها من
بينها وخرجت من بينها الزميل وائل الدحدوح
هذا القامه الصحفيه الفلسطينيه الذي اصبح
والجميع انا اقول صحيح ان في غزه ليس هناك
جبال ولا تلال هي ارض منبسطه لكن حق لنا
ان نقول فيها جبل صحفي اسمه وائل الدحدوح
وائل الدحدوح تحول الى ايقونه ايقونه
للصحفيين ايقونه
للفلسطينيين ايقونه لاهل غزه ايقونه ل كل
الصحفيين العرب لكل الصحفيين في في العالم
نعم نعم يعني حسن مشهد وائل يعني نضع
انفسنا يعني لك ان تتخيل تفقد الحفيد وتف
تقد الزوجه وتفقد يعني ثلاثه من الابناء
فقد محمود وكان له المكانه الخاصه الذي
كان يرى فيه الصحفي المستقبل الذي سوف
يحمل وائل الدحدوح فقد حمزه حقيقه كان
بالنسبه لوائل صديق اكثر من ابن كان
القريب الى القلب الذي رافقه وكان يحمل
معه حقيقه جزء من الذي صبر ابو حمزه بعد
استهداف العائله وفقدان الزوجه والابناء
هو حمزه الذي وقف الى جانب والده نسال
الله عز وجل ان يربط على قلبه وينزل على
السكينه ولا نملك في هذه اللحظات الا
الدعاء وكل